the royal family just got a little bit
bigger because princess beatrice and her
husband eduardo mapeli mozi just had a
baby i'm the sexy sassy grandma on
monday buckingham palace announced the
news that the 33 year old daughter of
prince andrew and sarah fergie ferguson
welcomed her first child with her
husband a property developer a statement
from the palace revealed they welcomed a
little girl but her name has not been
revealed yet she arrived at 11 42 pm at
the chelsea and westminster hospital in
london england weighing in at six pounds
two ounces the statement added that the
new baby's grandparents and
great-grandparents were all informed and
are delighted by the addition to the
family being a parent and now a
grandparent how how do you and andrew
grandparent together i have sort of
grandpa envy you know he's really good
he's a very good parent she's a very
good co-parent and he's a very deeply
kind man quote her royal highness and
her child are both doing well and the
couple are looking forward to
introducing their daughter to her big
brother christopher wolf christopher is
beatrice's five-year-old stepson back in
march the royal opened up to the evening
standard about her new role calling it a
great honor she also talked about
reading him bedtime stories explaining
quote i have dyslexia and as such
reading has never been my strongest
talent however having a little more time
to take a moment to really get into
stories has been a gift i am happy to
have shared with lockdown life
it's a sentiment she shared yet again
last month while speaking to hello when
asked about welcoming a new child into
the family i really see it as a gift
and
i think it's
life is a little bit about the moments
that make you
that challenge you or the ones that make
you
beatrice and her hubby tied the knot in
july 2020 in a surprise ceremony amid
the coronavirus pandemic at the time the
palace released a statement reading in
part quote the small ceremony was
attended by the queen elizabeth ii the
duke of edinburgh prince philip and
close family the news of beatrice's
growing family was announced on the
royal family's instagram page on may 19
with this snap alongside the caption
quote her royal highness princess
beatrice and mr eduardo mapelli mosey
are very pleased to announce that they
are expecting a baby in autumn of this
year the queen has been informed and
both families are delighted with the
news
[Music]